A pocas horas del inicio de los comicios
fue asesinado Omar Méndez era candidato
alcalde por la ciudad de Puerto López
serían cinco según los trascendidos los
candidatos asesinados no en esta
antesala de las elecciones como
transcurrió esta etapa previa Y a qué
atribuye estos hechos de violencia
efectivamente hemos tenido cinco
candidatos asesinados y otros dos y
atentados graves que se han cometido en
contra de la persona de ellos justamente
esta madrugada también sufrió un
atentado un ataque armado el candidato a
la alcaldía del cantón Palestina Me
parece que no es un secreto para nadie
la enorme crisis de seguridad por la que
atraviesa el Ecuador fuera de aquellos
Linderos de la delincuencia común mucho
se ha hablado de infiltraciones por
parte del crimen organizado eso sumado a
la poca reacción y margen de acción que
ha tenido el gobierno entonces
prácticamente desprotege a la ciudadanía
Qué representan bueno saliendo de este
clima de violencia no hablemos
concretamente de los comicios que
representan estas elecciones para
Guillermo lasso Cómo llega él
o sea las elecciones para Guillermo
lasso representarían un golpe de
confianza ante la imagen tan debilitada
que tiene su gobierno debido a la
escasez de productos y servicios
sociales que tanto se cuestionan aquí en
el Ecuador si bien en cierto se trata de
una consulta promovida por el poder
ejecutivo las posturas tanto a favor
como en contra de la consulta popular
lastimosamente han visto desplazada la
cuestión o el debate académico para
darle un tinte eminentemente político
dicho sea de paso la ambigüedad de las
preguntas y la ambigüedad de los anexos
ha generado una total confusión en la
ciudadanía Que prácticamente se acerca a
votar más por una responsabilidad
ideológica que propiamente social
concretamente hacia allí apunta a mi
próxima pregunta no quería preguntarle
sobre este referendo de ocho preguntas
impulsado como decíamos porque Guillermo
lasso genera muchas críticas No qué tema
abordan en general y cuáles considera
usted que son los puntos más
hay cuatro temas que resaltan en la en
la consulta académica Perdón la consulta
popular la extradición de Nacionales
hacia el extranjero la autonomía de la
fiscalía general del estado el consejo
de participación ciudadana algunas
reformas derivadas al código de la
Democracia también y por supuesto la
conservación y preservación de los
recursos naturales sobre el tema de la
extradición se ha dicho mucho Incluso el
gobierno va confundido términos como
expulsión y extradición que se han
sometido a debate constantemente ya no
solamente en los círculos académicos
sino también dentro de la población en
general se cuestiona mucho la completa
autonomía que se le quiere dar a la
fiscalía general del estado Porque si
bien es cierto sí tiene una competencia
Autónoma administrativa no podría ser la
fiscalía juez y parte considerando la
crisis social que nosotros estamos
viviendo y los constantes hechos de
corrupción que los agentes de la
fiscalía también se han encontrado
inmersos en los últimos tiempos de ahí
sobre el consejo de participación
ciudadana pues se dice que su única
finalidad es quitarle representación a
ciertos movimientos políticos